okay well i've got a little refracting
telescope this thing here
it feels a little bit um
belittled against
an 8.2 meter telescope there
but
it's fine
at the worst it'll be a pretty shot
but at the best we might get a hint of
green flash
[Music]
basically if you if the light from the
sun comes through the atmosphere um it
gets dispersed and you end up with
what's called a green rim and a red rim
the bottom half's got a red rim on it
the top half's got a green rim on it
so if you look at the sun in high
magnification you can see this really
thin
line of green around it now when the sun
gets really really low down and it's
light has to go through a really thick
layer of atmosphere
then sometimes that green detaches from
the sun itself and it can be hanging
there just at the last minute as the
sun's gone down below the horizon that's
what's called the green flash
so what i've done now is i've just
pointed that directly up at the moon
which is in about the most awkward
position it could possibly be in the sky
and i pre-focus this at infinity on the
moon so
when the sun goes really low down
and it's safe for me to turn the camera
round to look at it
it should be focused properly but i will
stress i'm not going to look through the
viewfinder i'm going to look on the back
of the screen so if everything goes
wrong because the air is very clear up
here then it's the camera that gets it
not me
[Music]
it's not long now
how's the battery looking the battery's
full
it's still quite a bright sun there
right it's beginning to go down below
the horizon now which means that the
sun's light will be getting
[Music]
more
tolerable
it doesn't look like a round ball
that's because the atmosphere is
distorting the shape of the sun
if you can see that
with the camera the top of the sun has
detached
[Music]
would it go green
[Music]
yes
wow
that was astonishing now the difficulty
is that the exposure was wrong
and it doesn't come out
as green it may over saturate
there whoa yes
you got it you got it baby
you're getting a bit closer for you
there that's just that's just the most
beautiful thing
i'm very very pleased with that
high five
[Music]
you